yeah yeah what i want to know is uh why
do you feel like you had to one up our
studio and uh build your own chris yeah
i mean i always i did i'll admit when i
came here i was like i want a space now
i've always wanted a space this is what
made you do it yeah i've got one of
those bastards
there might be three of them in the team
of 48 people well i'm going to one-up
them
by myself in a room with a massively
expensive set brilliant
i think i think you did one possibility
pewdiepie called me a son of a [ __ ]
because he was jealous
someone sent me a clip and pewdiepie is
like [ __ ] lebron japan the
studio is great i was pretty happy about
that
that's pretty smug about that that's
great
no like certainly when i gave me i was
like i don't know why i haven't got a
space yet i've always put like
unnecessary [ __ ] on myself like not
literally
shut up
sitting like across him because his eye
lines always [ __ ] there but he's
always finding a weak spot i i edited
all the broad japan videos by myself on
a macbook up until last year i didn't
use a desktop with a screen that sounds
like i literally talked to myself doing
a broadcast why would you do that do you
even have two screens
no
just a macbook so i only got an imac
like last year in a proper screen to
edit on and it's sort of 10 year almost
10 years in now it makes sense to have a
space yeah and honestly the most i've
used it for is just having meetings with
people and people come over it's better
than just like oh come on over to my
apartment watch out for the sock drawer
and the used family mark wrappers like
watch out
like it's nice to have a space where i
can actually sit and just create and do
things i guess to be fair though like 80
of your content is also outside as well
but that was because i had no space to
film it right in japan was born just me
an apartment complaining about how much
i hate what we had we had the uh 12 days
of christmas christmas
snickering at my clever title yeah so
clever really clever really clever that
came up that there was the word chris in
christmas christmas genius i finally
figured it out only i could have thought
that but uh yeah it's just cool space to
create and have somewhere like that that
ramen shop that's just sort of been in
my imagination for years to have that
sort of imaginary things imaginary set
translated to real life it's kind of
crazy thing and i've had some actual
serious film companies message me about
doing something in there oh so i'm from
like hollywood like we want to film some
stuff in there oh wow okay
um so it'll be interesting to see what
happens going forward how long does that
take to make like what was the entire
process around that so the guy came in
and i was like i want a ramen shop there
and a street there and he probably went
uh he got a tape measure pulled out an
ipad just went
like this
that's it but the man knew what he was
doing
it was a company called giuli i think
and they they built like sets for alice
in borderlands and they're looking for
paris netflix how did you find them just
through a friend he knew them he worked
with them and um and then they went away
they did a design they sent me like the
cgi what they look like and i was like
do that yeah that go
and uh and then they built it it took
about three weeks to build it in a
warehouse in chiba where they built
disneyland rides right oh wow there's
something like footage of like men
crafting lights and woodwork and
wow this is pretty intense and then took
three days to build it in the studio and
i wasn't there that time i think i was
on wacky weekend with you or something
when i was doing it and i came back to
sendai and i met the team and they were
all just like dead they like they hated
me they were like because usually they
build sets like film and tv yeah and my
like
my studio is like in a decrepit building
from the 60s it's like filled with
asbestos it's coming there's cracks over
the wall the building's coming down and
like they're like shifting like this
equipment through like an elevator and
stuff and they look dead and i was like
well done everyone they were like uh get
get me out of here
but uh yeah it wasn't cheap
obviously but it's kind of like uh
i mean
a lot of people sort of ask me how much
should it cost how much it costs but
like
i don't want to say because like
everyone will that will be like the
thing everyone thinks of right yeah yeah
consumed by that and yeah yeah it's
expensive but it's i could have spent
that professionals who do it for like
disney i mean yeah it's the best right
yeah it looks like it it shows it was it
was definitely shows i'll say it was in
the tens of thousands uh yeah oh yeah
yeah of course
like amount of electronics in that place
yeah the electronics elaine were almost
half the cost i think the most expensive
thing was the crafting the woodwork and
everything oh yeah they got the counter
bill cause i remember i saw the space
before you had it in there
i thought you were telling me there's
going to be this set here i was like no
you can't play that's why you were so
like shocked when you saw it right i was
like yeah i was like i was like you're
taking the piss you can't fit a set in
here it's like a [ __ ] bedroom like
yeah yeah you can't put anything in
there they're doing a great job with the
space they really like it's insane how
much they utilize they knew exactly what
they were doing
so much yeah it's like an investment in
myself for japan and um yeah because
you've been doing more content on your
second channel yeah yeah thank you for
christmas yeah probably christmas it's
definitely worth it
i remember when you i remember when you
told me about that early on you're like
i'm gonna upload daily for 12 days good
luck i've always got there i've always
got there
how was it doing the consistent content
back to back they remind me but it
reminded me why i don't do consistently
you don't have time to think do you you
i got a comment that really annoyed me
uh i don't get triggered that often
shut up
because i've been putting all these like
12 days of christmas on my second
channel yeah yeah yeah hello everyone's
got a second channel now it's cool
and uh
the race is on he's gonna have the
biggest second channel but like
someone's like he's just rehashing old
videos because we did i think i did a
video with you we just talked about
things that we don't like about japan
and we said
about how we nearly died and you know
just sitting down in the chat and i was
like come on mate like just
spend the entire [ __ ] year on
horseback or on a plane or a train on a
ferry like doing these videos can i just
sit in a room and talk about something
for five minutes like let me just chill
let me just sit in a room so
that's like the second channel yeah
that's the whole point of the second
channel we have like second channel
exactly technically our third channel
because i guess trash chase is our
second channel yeah it was like a really
cute tweet that was from a verified
account and i was tagged in it for some
reason and they were like chris for some
reason i can't seem to find these videos
on your channel
and they didn't realize that he had a
second channel
oh that's so cute
i don't know why i was like and then i
closed twitter
she told them nothing that's the only
wholesome thing i've ever read on
twitter that's awesome i was like i just
thought that christians have won one
place
but it's nice of a second channel as i'm
sure you guys have found it's nice to
just chill out because the pressure you
can put yourself on with the first
channel yeah yeah
sometimes you just have an idea for
content that you're like i can't put
this on my first channel sure yeah
exactly this is wait
no that's main channel content like joey
going through his health card school
yeah i went through my health card
school on my second channel what are you
doing then
bro
it would be like yes so everything's
great arch cholesterol's dreadful that's
basically what i said
yeah i mean i i i go to basically like
a's and b's and everything and then
urine came up and i got a c three and i
was just like how do i how do i [ __ ] up
in europe how do i how do i control my
obviously
i'm not being massage enough while i'm
urinating because something's going
wrong with that process did you have bad
blood last year has it gone up to a now
it's it's uh it's a b now okay that's
pretty much wrong with your earring
i have no idea it's like acidic i guess
drinking too much wine
too much green tea
what was your results chris
i have another test
let's get your results
if i don't know
when i was a teacher the first three
years they do it every year right yeah
my after my second year it was like
really bad because i'd smoked a lot and
i drank a lot of the time
the doctor like fell off his seat when
he saw that made your cholesterol look
healthy
he was like
it fell off the chair like humpty
[ __ ] dumpty like it was awful
and i had to spend the next year just
like eating a leaf and chicken
one leaf like a ladybug slowly
no no my cholesterol now must be
horrific
i'm worried about it
why am i laughing
laughing at my imminent demise i
understand because i have the similar
situation you're going to get tested
then or are you just going to put that
off
i don't really know
i don't have a big company backing me
don't just walk in be like put something
in my arm
it i think you're just going to like
yeah if you just bulk it you can get
like a full like like a standard health
checkup
you can make a content out of that
that's a that's another second channel
that's a second channel video right
there that's a narrative
content
did you do the thing we have to drink
barium and they like have it they're
radiating
i think that's if you have stomach
issues or when you're older i think they
do that but i'll probably choose that
one is it 40 you have to get a
colonoscopy
you have to get it yeah
it's poor businessman